هم يعرفون
حقائق والامور صحيح ولكن في ناحيتين اللي
ذكرت الماضي والثاني والثاني وهو بعد مهم
جدا ان ثاني اكسيد الكربون الذي يخرج من
البترول في السيارات والطائرات يؤثر كما
يقول يذكر العديد من العلماء على التغير
المناخ
الفارق اللي وجهه نظرنا نحن في المملكه
يقول ان العالم كله في حاجه للجميع مصادر
الطاقه سواء همم البترول او الغاز او
الطاقه المتجدده الطاقه الشمسيه ولكن يجب
ان نحمل على جهتين توسع او ثلاثه همم
محاوره توسع في انتاج الطاقه الشمسيه
وطاقه الرياح كما نعمل لها الثاني محاربه
محاربه همم
تغير المناخي وثاني اكسيد الكربون عن طريق
عن طريق
تخفيف الكميات
الناتجه عن هذا مثلا سمى المملكه بدات فيه
بشكل كبير اللي هو حقا اعاده حقن ثاني
الكربون في الحقول بدل ما يطلع لل-
والثالث طبعا مبادره ولي العهد الامير
محمد
المملكه الخضراء الشرق الاوسط المؤتمر شرم
يعني وهذه كل هذه الاشياء وهذه الطرق
وغيرها تساهم في تخفيض ال ال ال ال
البعثات من ناحيه وفي صالح البيئه بدل ما
انه حارب مصدر واحد لا يجب ان ننظر لها
بشكل اكبر